first fight goes his way and he spotted
the last man as well now rapping back
into ct and sicko gets it done
16-4
after the game we went outside and
talked and i just told them look each of
you i do love individually
but this won't stand it was a pretty big
gamble of course because like you don't
know if you're gonna like the game you
don't know if you're gonna do well in
the game and starting fresh is kind of
stressful too because you don't know who
you're gonna play with if you have a
couple bad matches people might think oh
you're so bad at this new game like you
should be playing this like go back to
cs magnum's in the smoky attempt oh my
god magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it
sentinels are the masters to reykjavik
champions and they do it flawlessly they
didn't drop a single map they are the
first global champions in valorant
history
[Music]
hunter sikh mimes was introduced to the
world of fps gaming through a familiar
avenue family from time to time sickwood
joined his father in playing one of the
greatest shooters the 2000's ever
produced battlefield 2. it was in the
streets of carkind and the beaches of
wake rissic not only developed his love
for the genre but built the foundation
that would later define him as the
ultimate team player so the first game i
ever played was battlefield 2 i played
with my dad
he was like he played with his military
buddies and um he got me into it and
i'll like fight helicopters and stuff
i'd be their medic i'd be a support
player now as typical as his
introduction was once sick got into cs
go he would quickly prove he was no
ordinary player and at just 16 years old
he competed in his first ever open
alongside fellow esca puck star weiss
together the two would hop between
different orgs until sick would catch
the interest of team solomid it was
there that stick would truly make a name
for himself already gets himself one
make it a second they're not going to
expect the third player to come in from
behind and actually sick has got two
headshots now it's down to the five hp
brothers both of them low on hp trying
to find this one back and six gonna do
it all still an opportunity to do
something with it and get a bomb down
and be fantastic first kill which he
does takes out kerrigan but there are
any cts do you know exactly where he is
there's a lot of work to do but that's
great start one-on-one now against the
begs i'm just gonna go down this is
actually well pulled back by sick
they've got the great chance here ak's
got the advantage well in terms of
firepower and that there's no kit so
this is actually tsm's to steal and
stick is going to do exactly that takes
down zips and for a period sick was the
epitome of na's future in cs he still
had a ways to go in developing his mind
for the game but his entry fragging
ability and aim were a sight to behold
there are three people almost four
making their way stick has putting great
work here so far so good two down
automatically gonna get traded by nade
from flashlight sick is tapping everyone
all of a sudden it's two versus two
they've got time to fly the bombing
looking for his uh next one indeed he
could get a fourth as well it's crims
alone all of a sudden what's happened to
fnatic but at the same time sick was
rising in prominence so was his teammate
another young player quickly became
infamous for his pinpoint precision
twists despite the two being great
players twist was slowly overshadowing
sick in the na market eventually twists
would get picked up by team liquid and
sick would stay behind continuing his
grind awp also rotating on from cirque
staying on the a site itself sick does
get one degree down when it comes
through i do not believe this is a 3k
for sick over the next two years sick
would make it to three majors on three
separate teams but his best result was a
third to fourth place finish with tsm
despite the poor results complexity took
a chance and signed sick to the team
reuniting him with fellow nacs grinder
shazam but after a dismal appearance at
the starladder major sick was benched
after the game we went outside and
talked and i just told them look each of
you i do love individually but this is
completely not acceptable and i'm going
to be posting some things on twitter i'm
going gonna be dropping some bombs and i
just wanted to tell you face to face
this is not
about you personally
but this won't stand and the ushering in
of the online era only made things worse
for sick he stood in for a few different
teams but found little success but in
the spring of 2020 a new opportunity
came calling a chance for him to start
over and put his skill to the test in a
new game however the decision would not
be made lightly if you're leaving cs go
for it was like
it was a pretty big gamble of course
because like
you don't know if you're gonna like the
game you don't know if you're gonna do
well in the game and starting fresh is
kind of stressful too because you don't
know who you're gonna play with
if you have a couple bad matches people
might think oh you're so bad at this new
game like you should be playing this
like go back to cs sick didn't just want
to compete in valorant he wanted to
dominate unfortunately for him his
longtime cs teammate shazam felt the
same way uh in closed beta
me and six started on building a team
and we decided that you know there's
gonna be a lot of people that are
hesitant to switch careers after playing
cs so long we decided that if we want to
become the best in this game like we
need to find people that are fully
committed to valerian and so that's when
we built the team soon after sick
announced his departure from
counter-strike sentinels revealed their
valerent roster the first few
tournaments were a little rocky but it
was to be expected since two of the
team's players came from games that
weren't cs go but once they got rolling
sentinels were nearly impossible to stop
despite valorant being a cs go clone
sentinels didn't treat it like one they
fully bought into the changing metas and
their versatility as players allowed
them to push certain agents to their
full potential
[Applause]
and whether it was on stream or in a
tournament sick continued to prove that
his mechanics were a universal language
what the [ __ ] is happening
what is going on dude
mitch is going to be creeping around the
corner cold with this op and the
connection's not there and sick clutches
it after the plan oh you let him know
sentinels went on to win a ton of big
events that year including the pop flash
and the jbl cup and once tenz came in to
replace sinatra sentinels truly took
over the na-valrant scene not gonna spot
him out just yet sick does do that
chipped away to half hp around the
corner and zeta needs to hang on a 1v1
zom's full hp 52 health for the sova as
he looks to re-swing that's gonna do it
zombs will sit him down sick dapper zomb
shazam and tens sentinels pack your bags
you're headed to iceland with the boys
firing on all cylinders sentinels looked
unstoppable and iceland and will go on
to make history for not just valorant
but all of na esports oh my god gets
blessed the team flash the team flash
magnum's in the smokey attempts oh my
god magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it sentinels are the
masters to reikobic champions and they
do it flawlessly they didn't drop a
single map they are the first global
champions in valor and history things
were finally working out for na for the
first time in a long time fans had
something to cheer about the region was
finally better than the rest of the
world and it was thanks to a bunch of
so-called washed up misfits and perhaps
maybe the most underrated piece of that
puzzle was sick you see back in cs sick
was a pretty aggressive rifler but by
the time they won in iceland sick
changed a lot as a player now set can
basically do it all time and time again
his team has called on him to adapt and
stick does it without hesitation a sick
is not the type of player to do a
half-assed job every role that he plays
he plays to the highest possible level
he is better on his third fourth fifth
agent than some people are when that's
their primary that's incredible when the
team first started sick was playing a
lot of sage supporting his team the same
way he helped his father a decade prior
later he would take on duelist
characters like phoenix and reyes
proving once again that his aim and
entry fracking chops were still top tier
now flash goes in sick makes the push he
finds one point oh
the man's living up to his name as time
went on sick would even add more agents
to his pool breech then skye then silva
and now ko how sick would even play
astra if it was needed most pros juggle
about three agents but sick has played
eight different agents competitively
across every unique role in the game
even people outside valrant noticed his
evolution as a pro nowadays when i watch
him obviously every time he's evolved
he learns so it's nice to see him
succeeding because i always thought he
was a solid fragger and now that
nowadays on ballerin when you see him be
more versatile and playing other roles
and being able to do it all like
pretty sick but as a result of being
such an incredibly flexible player sick
had to sacrifice his chance to be in the
spotlight between tens creating some of
the game's craziest highlights and
dapper teabagging every server there
isn't always much room for sick in the
headlines but that doesn't mean he is
undeserving soul tens is doing backflips
on jet and shazam is leading the charge
sick is the rock solid constant
sentinel's needs yeah things clear in
that meticulously but esperanza and the
gang walking mid now they know there's
more stick with a lovely flash and the
spray is sublime and this is what i like
seeing ant box once again having a bit
more of an emphasis
but
they have learned their lesson and he
does the 360 first i don't even know but
that is what sweet play and somehow
within the rapidly growing and
avalarance scene six cold killer
reputation has allowed his stream to
grow outside the server a place where
you can expect tons of cat petting some
classic ranked molding and if you want
tips on how to play basically every
agent in the game just be prepared for
six notorious dry wit and sarcasm
oh
i learned now
yeah
thank you chad thing is with that we
lost on purpose just so the group would
be a little bit more entertaining for
everybody just because like obviously if
you win every match in the group there's
no point of even watching unfortunately
six valorent timeline hasn't been all
sunshine in rainbows although sick and
other sentinel players have grown in
popularity the results of the team since
iceland haven't been as stellar they
were still at the top of the north
american scene but they failed to
impress at ballarat's next two
international events dapper it's your
time to shine right about now it's all
on you buddy surrounded all fronts it's
over it's done with crew against all
of our expectations against all odds
send sentinels
and at the start of the 2022 season
things went from bad to worse for
sentinels as they were knocked out of
the vctna challengers playoffs losing
their reign as the kings of north
america enough to work with though and
now only two players left alive for
sentiments this could be it this could
be the finale dapper left alone and it
cannot be done it's version one who are
gonna be knocking out the former
reykjavik champions
who's to say what sentinel's future
looks like by all margins valerian is
still a very new esport and metas are
constantly changing what we do know is
that the talent is still there and in
the case of sick he's still performing
well flexing agents and helping out his
team in any way he can and here comes
the flank the door gets open nobody's
turning around so he gets the kill there
on to neptune but at least the toxic
screen the viper pit it's now down on
the attack but it's still gonna be a one
versus one with sick getting that kill
in the end but how about it ganks was
actually able to not just take them down
but actually finds the third in the
round leading into a 1v1 ziff does
collect a rifle
so an even battle largely speaking but
sick holds it tight boys towards the
behind but they're working together now
six on his own it's a one versus one he
just gets the second one right there for
the red bull clutch when we take a step
back and reflect on six careers so far
it's hard not to notice something more
than other players with similar
backgrounds and stories six experiences
have had such a clear effect on who he
is now he ground it out in an a got
invaluable knowledge from veterans even
played alongside foreign talent and
regardless of sentinel's future sick has
proven to be one of na's greatest
players in this young game and just a
fraction of what he's accomplished so
far has made his move to valrant the
best decision of his career
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tech talk